WALTER ISAACSON: You know,
we're very, very lucky here.
I mean, when I
wrote this block, I
thought, who are the
great heroes of it,
and Dr. Khan and Vint
Cerf are among them,
and I hope you appreciate
how cool it is, especially
for somebody like me
who loves history,
to be able to talk the
internet with you all.
VINT CERF: Well, it's a real
pleasure to have you here
and to have the rest of you
here in our new offices.
For those of you who
came in more on time,
we kind of started
just informally.
This man sitting
next to me has had
quite an interesting
history, so I'll
repeat a little bit of that.
He's currently the chairman
of the Aspen Institute
and was formerly
the chairman of CNN.
He was also managing
editor of Time Magazine
and has written a whole bunch of
books, the most recent of which
you have before you,
"The Innovators."
The most recent before that
was Steve Jobs's biography
and many others before
that, all of which
are well worth reading, so we
welcome you to our presence
and to an opportunity to ask you
some questions about this book.
Sitting over on my
right is Bob Kahn.
I was going to say the late Bob
Kahn, that would be bad taste,
so I won't do that.
BOB KAHN: Wasn't that late.
Your problem is your garage
says it closes at 7 o'clock,
so we were about to go find
some other garage to park in.
VINT CERF: Well,
since we're all here,
I can make the
door open for you.
How's that?
WALTER ISAACSON: All you
have to do is say, OK, glass,
open the door.
VINT CERF: That's it.
I'm wearing one right there.
BOB KAHN: Is the
audience all from Google?
VINT CERF: No, no, no.
These are people from
all over the place.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Who's from Google?
VINT CERF: Fair number
but not everybody.
So what I thought
we would do, Bob,
is start out with a couple of
questions about the book itself
and what Walter has discovered.
This thing covers
quite a broad range
of topics about things
that were highly innovative
and made huge changes
in our history.
So what is it that
you would distill
from what you've
already discovered
in writing the book that you
would like us to take away?
WALTER ISAACSON:
Thank you, and let
me say that when we
get further along
and we're discussing
the internet,
I'm going to turn the
tables because to be
able to ask questions
of the two of you
about both the ARPANET,
the RFCs, and then
the internet protocols.
So watch out because that's
going to be a two way street.
VINT CERF: Fair deal.
WALTER ISAACSON: The
main thing I discovered.
I've written biographies
a lot-- Steve Jobs,
Einstein, Franklin--
and those of us
who write biographies kind of
know in the back of our minds
that we distort history with
the great man theory of history.
We make it sound like there's
a guy or a gal in a garage
or a garret who has a light bulb
moment and innovation happens.
True innovation, and there's
no better example of it
then the ARPANET RFC process
and then the TCP/IP process,
really comes from pairs of
people, teams of people,
and from collaboration, bouncing
ideas off against each other,
finishing each
other's sentences,
and the internet
age in particular
allows such teamwork
and collaboration.
The other thing was I started
this book when I said,
way earlier before
we started, we
were talking about when I ran
digital media for Time Inc
in the early 1990s, and I first
met Vint when he was at MCI,
and I was trying to convince
Time Inc to do things
with the internet.
And so the president of
Time Inc says to me, well,
who owns the internet?
So first of all,
I think to myself
because I don't
want to get fired,
that's a clueless question.
I say, nobody owns it.
He says, well, who built it?
Who created it?
And I realized
after thinking how
clueless that question was
that I did not really now.
And if you feel detached from
the history of the things you
use, there's sort of a
detachment that leads to you
not feeling comfortable with it.
So I wanted to know, how
did computers happen?
How did the PC happen?
How did the transistor
become the microchip,
and then how did the internet or
digital packet switch networks
come into being?
So that's why I did this book,
and in doing so, as I said,
you learn about the
importance of collaboration,
but you also learn
that there wasn't
one person who
invented the computer.
And certainly, even
after doing this book,
you and I have been
discussing some of the,
no, I should get more
credit type feelings,
but it was done creatively
and collaboratively.
VINT CERF: This notion
of collaboration
resonates very
well with all of us
at Google because a lot of
the tools that we make and use
are exactly
collaborative elements,
things like Shared Documents,
things like the Google
Hangouts, things like that
where multiple parties can
communicate all
at the same time.
WALTER ISAACSON: That was
the original intention
of the internet or
ARPANET was time
sharing research computers,
and then collaborating.
I even did that with this book.
When I was writing
that, I said, wait,
this is how we collaborate,
and I put parts of this book
online, like on a medium
with Google Docs, whatever,
and said, everybody share.
Help me collaborate.
Help put stuff in.
And people like Stewart
Brand, who I knew,
started rewriting the demise
of the Whole Earth Catalog,
and exactly what drugs were
being served at the demise
partly because I
got the drugs wrong.
But people like Dan
Bricklin were explaining,
no, VisiCalc was done this way.
And so they're in the book
from having been crowd sourced.
BOB KAHN: Walter, I'd like
to ask you a question.
Vint and I were both on a
panel at the National Academy
about a week ago, and one of
the questions that came up was,
what is the internet?
One of the panelists
took the position
that the internet is
what people think it is.
So if you think the
web is the internet,
then that's the internet.
If you think the web is this.
I just wondered,
do you care much
in writing a book like that
of clarifying that example.
Because a lot of places
in the book, you say,
the ARPANET morphed
into internet, and not
exactly clear what the internet
is from reading your book.
Are you comfortable
with that definition?
WALTER ISAACSON: I
see the internet,
and I'm going to turn it to
you, because you should answer
it better, but I see it
as the TCP/IP protocols.
Now, the question is
when Tim Berners-Lee
puts a layer of that [INAUDIBLE]
that have hypertext protocols
and markup languages, to me,
that's still the internet.
Now, the question then
becomes, if I'm using Twitter,
is that the internet?
And the answer
technically is no.
I mean, that's not--
VINT CERF: Well, actually,
we could argue that because--
WALTER ISAACSON: Oh,
we could argue it,
so let me turn it
back to you all.
VINT CERF: Wait, wait, wait.
You're right in the
middle of chapter six,
and I wanted to at
least point out to you--
WALTER ISAACSON:
Start at chapter one?
VINT CERF: Well, we don't have
to go through every chapter
but this starts out
with Ada Lovelace, who
was Lord Byron's daughter.
And I wanted to start
out by just asking, what
was it that drew you
to that story first,
because it's in the
1850s in England,
and it's the earliest
manifestations
of mechanical computing?
What made you decide
to start there?
WALTER ISAACSON:
To be honest, what
drew it to me first was my
daughter had not written
her college entrance essay,
and my wife, who we've talked
about, was going nuts the way
Yuppie wives do, and saying,
get it done.
And one day, Betsy
said, I did it.
I said, what was it on?
She said, Ada
Lovelace because she's
a computer geek and stuff.
And I paused.
I kind of knew the
name Ada Lovelace,
but I didn't know
exactly what she did.
VINT CERF: You didn't mix
it up with Linda Lovelace?
WALTER ISAACSON: No, I did not.
I'm surprised that people
all remember who she is.
So I became much more
interested in Ada Lovelace.
Now, Ada Lovelace is partly
a symbol in this book,
because as a person, she's
kind of controversial,
but what she does as
Lord Byron's daughter is
her mother, Lady Byron, was
optically fond of Lord Byron
by the time Ada was growing
up, for reasons that Byron
fans will understand, and
so had her tutored mainly
in mathematics as if that were
an antidote for her becoming
a romantic poet, which Lady
Byron did not want her to be.
So she embraces what she
calls poetical science.
It's the ability to link
the poetic and the beauty
of humanities with the
technology of science.
She loves, for example,
traveling the Midlands
and looking at the
punch cards that
are being used in the mechanical
looms of the Industrial
Revolution in the 1830s.
VINT CERF: The
Jacquard looms, yes.
WALTER ISAACSON:
The Jacquard loom,
and showing how
they weave patterns.
Her father, Lord
Byron, was a Luddite,
and I don't mean
that figuratively.
His only speech in
the House of Lords
was defending the
followers of Ned Ludd, who
were smashing these
looms because they
were putting people out of work.
And he also is there
with Mary Shelley
when they do
Frankenstein's monster.
This notion that
technology can destroy us
was ingrained in Lord Byron.
Ada felt the opposite.
She had this friend,
Charles Babbage,
who had made a pretty
good calculator called
the difference
engine, was trying
to conceive one
which he never got
built called the
analytical engine, which
uses punch cards to do the
processing of the numbers.
Ada writes a set of notes
that are totally fascinating.
You've got to read them.
And among the
notes to this thing
is how if you use punch
cards, the machine
will be able to weave
patterns like Jacquard's loom,
as she puts it.
In other words, the machine will
not only do numbers, she says.
You can make it do
words, or even music.
I can feel her father
rolling over in the grave.
Patterns, anything that can be
notated in symbols, she said.
So to me, that is
the core notion
of what a computer is, anything
that can be notated in symbols.
She has many other
things, but I'll
only mention one, which
is her final note is
that they'll do
anything but think.
Machines will never be creative.
Machines will never think.
And 100 years later,
assuming you're
going to jump there, Alan
Turing, who really comes up
with the concept of the
universal computing machine,
and then works at Bletchley
Park to break the German ENIGMA
code with some people.
They build the Bombe
and then Colossus.
He writes a wonderful paper.
The movie's about to come out
called "The Imitation Game."
He called it the imitation game.
We now call the
Turing test to address
what he calls Lady
Lovelace's objection,
because Turing was
fascinated by Lovelace.
And he says, well, you say
machines will never think.
How would we know that?
If you had a machine in a
different room and a person,
you couldn't tell
their answers apart,
you'd have no empirical reason
to say machines don't think.
And so he believed in
artificial intelligence,
that eventually, we would have
machines that think without us.
I basically use that as
one of the framing devices
in the book, the
notion of those who
believe that the intimate
partnership between humans
and machines will get
us forward and those
who believe that the pursuit
of artificial intelligence
will get us forward.
Sorry for the long answer.
BOB KAHN: One of
the first programs
that I ever used--
Vint actually wrote one
about PARRY and the DOCTOR.
This is about the
DOCTOR program.
It made some
outrageous statement,
and it was supposed to be
a conversation about you.
I remember when I saw that, I
responded to it, "my oh my,"
and its response back
was, "your oh your?"
And I knew we
wouldn't get very far.
WALTER ISAACSON: With all due
respect to my Google Android's
ability to talk to
me, it is really hard
to do language processing.
VINT CERF: Yes.
We have a lot of people
who have confirmed that.
BOB KAHN: And we know quite a
bit about it from [INAUDIBLE].
WALTER ISAACSON: You
know more than anybody.
VINT CERF: The
earliest experience
I ever had with trying to
do language translation
was at Stanford when I was an
undergraduate in the 1960s,
and we were pretty naive.
We had this
Russian/English dictionary,
and we poured it
into the computer.
We typed in, "out of
sight, out of mind."
We translated that
into Russian, then
we translated it
back into English,
and it came back,
"invisible idiot."
[LAUGHTER]
Which told us that
there was more
to this than the dictionary.
WALTER ISAACSON: By
the way, the book
ends with a chapter called
"Ada Forever," which
is what you just said, this
notion of understanding
a bit of language, or being
able to spot your mother's
face in Grand Central
Station, which
if you go to the total
domain awareness system
down in lower Manhattan,
they have all these cameras.
They say, oh, we can do that.
Or a robot that can walk across
the room and pick up a crayon.
A four-year-old can do
it but a machine can't.
It's called Moravec's paradox.
VINT CERF: It's
getting better, though.
WALTER ISAACSON: It's
always getting better,
but it's always 20 years away.
It's always a mirage.
VINT CERF: Look, the
latest Tesla announcement,
the D thing parks itself.
We're getting closer and
closer to something useful,
even if it isn't as
fully creative as--
WALTER ISAACSON: I
was onstage yesterday
with Elon Musk, who told me that
the singularity is so close he
wants to go to Mars because
machine learning will make
machines want to destroy us,
and he's smarter than I am.
You all at Google
are smarter, but I've
been reading that since
1955 right after Alan Turing
does his Turing test, and they
always say, 10 years from now,
we'll have machines that
can think better than we do.
Maybe so, but as the
heroes of this book,
Lick Licklider, Doug Engelbart,
Alan Kay, say, in the meantime,
let's make our machines
connect to us better
than try to out-think us.
VINT CERF: Well, let's
make partners out of them,
if nothing else.
I have to admit Google search
is a pretty cool partner when
you think about it.
It does stuff that
I couldn't do.
WALTER ISAACSON:
And Google search
is done not by an algorithm
that thinks without us,
but an algorighm that
harvests millions of links
put every day onto
websites by humans.
VINT CERF: That's right.
BOB KAHN: I wanted to ask you
one question about something
that struck me when I
first really understood
what Turing and company
were doing at Princeton.
I gave the keynote at the
100th anniversary of his birth.
VINT CERF: His birthday.
BOB KAHN: Last year [INAUDIBLE].
It was one of a
multiplicity of them.
But one of the
things that struck
me back then was
when Turing wrote
that paper on computable
numbers, that was actually
not easily accepted by people
because they didn't think
computing was something that a
machine could do at that time,
really.
If you looked at what Church
did with the lambda calculus,
it was a conceptual thing.
If you looked at what his
colleagues, like Kurt Godel,
and there were a number of
really excellent logicians
there at the time,
they were thinking
of conceptual frameworks
for organizing things
so that the logic made sense.
WALTER ISAACSON: You have
to remember that, as you do,
uncomputable numbers
was not written
to invent a universal
computing machine.
That was just a
thought experiment
he uses to solve
one of Hilbert's
mathematical questions about
whether all problems are
decidable.
BOB KAHN: But it seems to me
that the one thing that really
came out of that was the
idea that you could actually
create a machine that would
do these computations.
They eventually showed
that recursive function
theory and the lambda calculus
and the Turing machine all
could do all the
computable functions,
but that wasn't known at the
time, nor was it obvious.
The realization that
pops out at that time
that you can actually
build something
around these numbers
that was so fascinating,
but I didn't get
that out of the book,
and I wondered, was that
something you just didn't think
the public would
understand, or was--
WALTER ISAACSON: I thought
that was important, totally
fascinating.
I drilled down, read
the entire Turing thing.
That is a sideline
because it's not
about the actual what they were
doing at Bletchley Park, which
I was trying to tell.
BOB KAHN: This was at Princeton.
WALTER ISAACSON: Right.
What happens there, and I
would love your feedback on it,
is they are trying to figure
out whether all problems are
computable, whether it's
decidable to know which ones
or not, and you
end up with Godel
saying there's an incompleteness
inherent, and with Turing
and Church both saying,
and we can't even
decide what is completable
and what's not completable.
I'm oversimplifying.
So there's still
a mystery that's
wonderfully inherent in math,
that not all things-- I mean,
there is an incompleteness
in the mathematical system.
BOB KAHN: But there
was also the fact,
I believe, that
what Turing had done
was not appreciated that much
by the other people around him
because they were the
pure theoreticians,
and Turing was more
of an engineer,
if I can use that term, even
though he never built anything,
much like the conflicts that
we've seen in computer science
in recent days
between the people who
are the pure theorists and
the people who are actually
building stuff.
WALTER ISAACSON: You're
absolutely right,
and I do say in
the book that there
are only four or five people
who even comment or review
his paper.
It's not very well thought of.
And throughout history,
you see that where Penn,
they're building
these computers,
and yet it seems a little
beneath their dignity
because it's not an academic,
theoretical pursuit,
so then they get
rid of the computer.
And even at Princeton,
if I may say,
the IAS finally, after
von Neumann leaves,
they don't feel computing is a
grand endeavor in its own way.
BOB KAHN: Well,
there was physics.
WALTER ISAACSON: Yes, right.
VINT CERF: Well,
everything is physics
when you get right down to it.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Everything is math.
VINT CERF: Well, OK.
So we start with math
and we go to physics,
and the abstraction of
physics is chemistry,
chemistry is biology,
and the abstraction of
biology is psychology,
and it keeps on going like that.
BOB KAHN: But you remember
the symposium we had up at MIT
when Richard Feynman came
and a bunch of others,
and it was called "The
Simulation of Physics,"
and they didn't like that
one bit because they said,
physics is not a simulation.
It's not some bigger, digital
thing that's creating it.
WALTER ISAACSON: You're
losing control of the bus.
VINT CERF: I'll come back
to a couple of things.
Well, it's impossible.
Nobody could manage these guys.
But I do want to draw you back
for just a couple seconds.
First of all, the point
about Turing, for example,
reinforces the notion
that theory is helpful
if you can underwrite or
underscore or somehow support
applications.
If you don't have much theory
underneath the application,
then you don't quite
know what to expect
and what you're doing.
So it's clear that the
Gedankenexperiment that Turing
did is not unlike the
Gedankenexperiments
that Einstein did.
A lot of his work was not math.
It was Gedanken imagery.
He thought in those terms.
WALTER ISAACSON: Visual
thought experiment.
VINT CERF: Now let's go to
something more concrete,
though.
You have a really
interesting story
here about what happens when the
transistor gets built in 1947.
The three guys who do this go
off-- well, Shockley anyway,
goes off to start a company
to build transistors.
And I think it's
worth recounting
what happens because
the focus that we got
to early in this game
was collaboration
and what happens when you get
groups of people all focused
on trying to do something.
So what happens in that case?
Shockley goes to the West
Coast and starts his company,
brings some really
smart people together,
which should have produced
an important collaboration.
What happened?
WALTER ISAACSON: It goes to
the theme of the book, which
is that vision without
collaboration and execution
is just hallucination.
What you have at Bell Labs
is this wonderful environment
where Shannon is riding a
unicycle up and down doing
information theory,
but you also have--
VINT CERF: Did he do
that when you were there?
WALTER ISAACSON: Yes.
BOB KAHN: Shannon had left.
I started my career
at Bell Labs.
One of the things I
got from your book
that I found very
interesting was
he started at the
same place that I did,
which was 463 West
Street in New York.
WALTER ISAACSON: Right on
Greenwich Village's side
of the Hudson.
BOB KAHN: It was right
on the Hudson River,
and you could watch the
Queen Mary and Queen
Elizabeth coming
in every Tuesday
and going out every Thursday.
WALTER ISAACSON: It's still
a wonderful warehouse,
and then they moved
it to New Jersey.
BOB KAHN: Murray Hill existed
at the time that I was there.
I think it probably
didn't when he was there.
WALTER ISAACSON: It
becomes a cauldron
in which you have information
theorists, quantum theorists,
like Shockley to some extent,
and certainly Bardeen.
VINT CERF: Bardeen for sure.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Walter Brattain,
who is a great experimentalist,
but also people with grease
under their fingernails who've
climbed a pole to figure out,
how are we going to amplify
a phone signal between New
York and San Francisco,
and they collaborate.
They work together.
They have a little
bit of a problem
once the collaboration was
over, does Shockley get
to be in the pictures
with Bardeen and Brattain,
and who gets credit and
who gets a Nobel Prize,
but before you fight over Nobel
Prizes, you collaborate well.
Shockley was really
bad at collaboration,
and he got worse, and the
Nobel Prize didn't help.
I'm glad we've not
all won one yet
because it made him
into a bit of a jerk.
He goes off and he forms
Shockley Semiconductor,
and he gets more and more
uncollaborative with his team,
and more and more
top down dictatorial,
unlike, say, a
[INAUDIBLE] environment.
VINT CERF: Hiding his research
results from other people.
WALTER ISAACSON: Hiding his
research from his own people,
making them take
lie detector tests,
worrying who's going
to get the credit.
So obviously, the
great thing about it
is it disintegrates because
of this, and the people who
fly off from this big bang
are so allergic to Shockley's
way of doing things that they
move to the other extreme, two
of the best examples being
Gordon Moore and Bob Noyce,
who form Fairchild
Semiconductor,
and then eventually form Intel.
VINT CERF: Why was it called
Fairchild Semiconductor?
WALTER ISAACSON:
Because they did not
have venture
capitalists back then,
so they wanted to start their
own semiconductor company,
but they couldn't just
go to Sandhill Road
and tell Kleiner Perkins,
give me an investment.
Arthur Rock was just
starting, and so he
helped put it together.
Arthur Rock was not yet
a venture capitalist.
He was still a
banker from the east.
So he calls his east coast
buddies-- IBM, Bell-- and says,
do you want a
division we can start
that will make semiconductors?
And they'll say, no,
we don't want that.
We don't want an
autonomous division.
We don't want to
give them the power.
He's just about to
give up and then went
to Sherman Fairchild, who's a
bit of a nutcase and a playboy
and always out in
nightclubs and 21 Club.
They make a deal and
Sherman Fairchild says,
yeah, I'll stake you.
I'll make you a Fairchild
Semiconductor division.
They were also doing
cameras and aircraft.
And of course, it becomes
the biggest division
in the company, and
eventually, Fairchild
exercises the right to buy
them out, after which Noyce
and Moore start their
own company, Intel.
VINT CERF: That's amazing.
So this is sort of like one
of those black hole explosion
things that--
WALTER ISAACSON: Well, they
call them fairchildren,
because Fairchild
then breaks up a bit,
and if you look at Silicon
Valley, you can do a Google map
and just say
Fairchild, and you'll
see all the companies
that spun off.
BOB KAHN: You know,
there are actually
two parallel stories with
Intel and the work that
went on before that
are interesting.
You focused on one
of them in the book,
and I knew two of
those people very well.
I've met Gordon Moore, but
I knew Bob Noyce very well,
interacted with him a
lot, especially when
I was doing the DLSI
program at DARPA
and he was fighting the
VISIC program in the DoD.
And the other was Andy
Grove, who was in my class
in undergraduate
school, so I knew him.
WALTER ISAACSON:
That's in New York.
BOB KAHN: At City College, yes.
So I knew those two well.
But the other story
that's quite interesting
is who gets the credit
for the microcomputer.
WALTER ISAACSON:
The microprocessor
or microcomputer?
BOB KAHN: The
microprocessor in this case.
VINT CERF: This is after the
integrated circuit, about which
there was another big argument.
BOB KAHN: That's right.
This was in the early '70s, when
Intel was trying to figure out
internally how you connect
one piece to another piece,
and instead of
doing a one of, they
decided, let's build
a programmable thing.
So you have a guy named
Frederico Faggin, who actually
did the actual
implementation of it.
You had a guy named Ted Hoff,
who is credited by everybody,
and Bob Noyce told me,
when he was pushing
some of the nominations
for awards for him,
that he was sort of the
architect of the whole thing.
But you had it all
done in a lab that
was run by a fellow
named Les Vadez,
and Les always
claimed that he set
the environment and the tone,
which enabled it all to happen.
Between three of them,
they don't really
necessarily all see the
development the same way.
WALTER ISAACSON: You
know, it's a shame,
and that happens a lot.
And in this book, I'm
already getting emails,
and you are, too.
I won't name names
because we're online,
but people say, he didn't
quite give me enough-- oh,
actually now I've read it,
he give me enough credit.
The one I love is
Kilby, as you know,
Jack Kilby does it at Texas
Instruments, the microchip.
I'm moving back earlier,
the integrated circuit.
And Noyce does it at
approximately the same time
and separately.
And Kilby wins the Nobel
Prize, and unlike Shockley, it
doesn't go to is head.
And he also says, if Bob
Noyce was still alive,
he'd be sharing
this prize with me.
They both deserve it.
They don't give Nobel
Prizes when you're--
VINT CERF: Kilby didn't get
that award until he was 82,
and he passed away a
couple years later.
WALTER ISAACSON: But when
they finally bring Kilby
and he's awarded it, the
Norwegian scientist introducing
him says, everything we have
in the digital revolution
comes from what you did.
And Kilby says, that reminds
me of what the beaver said
to the rabbit at the
foot of the Hoover Dam,
which is, no, I didn't
build it, but it
is based on an idea of mine.
One of the things
about collaboration
is it gets hard to
allocate credit,
and I try very hard
in this book to say,
OK, here's how I would parse
the credit for the computer.
I mean, is it basically
Mauchly and Eckert at Penn?
Is it Atanasoff at Iowa State?
Microchip, transistor?
We all want to parse out
credit, whether we're
intellectual property lawyers
fighting over the patents,
whether we're Nobel
Prize jurists,
or whether we're biographers,
and I tried to minimize,
and you and I were
talking beforehand.
There's dispute
amongst the people
who conceived of
packet switching, which
are three or four
or five people.
They all fight over it.
They're all quoted by name
on the record, will tell you,
oh, this guy's an idiot.
I try to say, no, it
was the collaboration.
Packet switching
was an amazing idea.
It is the heart of,
obviously, what you two did,
and I was slightly
annoyed by the people who
wanted to disparage
their colleagues'
contribution because there is
enough credit to go around.
VINT CERF: Exactly, and this
emphasizes several things.
The first one is a
lot of stuff happens
because it's now
possible to happen.
The economics are possible or
the amount of memory available
makes it possible or the speed
of something makes it possible,
and so concurrent
invention is not
unusual under those
circumstances.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Especially, there
was a miracle year
of 1939, let me say,
where conceptual breakthroughs
have happened, including
Turing's papers published
on universal computing,
but Shannon and other
people are starting
to apply Boolean algebra to
how to do it in circuits.
But you also have mechanical
inventions, including
the vacuum tube and
telephone switchboards,
that have come together,
but you also have the drums
of war, both in Germany
with Herman Zuse,
and at Bletchley
Park in England,
and at Aberdeen Proving
Ground in the United States.
It's dawning on people that
firepower is actually not
going to be as important as
computing power in winning
the next war, and
so that's why I'm
convinced that you have a
fertile ground from 1940
to '45 for the creation
of the computer.
And likewise,
another fertile stew
happens, which
Google is part of it
out in California,
Mountain View and all,
that in the early '70s, there
was just this yeasty brew
of counterculture types,
electronic geeks, people who
had been in the
defense industry,
people who had read the Whole
Earth Catalog once too often,
all of whom are coming
together and want computing
power to the people to take it
back from the big corporations,
and they're creating the
Altair and the Apple and all
those machines.
VINT CERF: I was waiting for
you to leap into something.
BOB KAHN: I have so many
thoughts going through my mind,
I'm not sure where
to jump into this.
One of the questions
I had about the book
was, what prompted you
to choose the things
that you did to emphasize?
It's a wonderful read.
WALTER ISAACSON: That's the
toughest of all questions.
BOB KAHN: About the
only complaint I have is
that you couldn't
touch everything
with uniform treatment.
So for example, there are things
that don't show up here at all,
like, for example,
the role that NSF
played in bringing
the internet out.
There are people who I think
played an important role that
never get mentioned, like
Steve Wolf is a good example.
VINT CERF: Absolutely.
Gordon Bell.
BOB KAHN: I just wondered,
this is a reflection
on what you felt you
wanted to write about.
WALTER ISAACSON: I had
about a 1,000 page book.
BOB KAHN: How did you
get to this rendition?
WALTER ISAACSON: When
I did all my notes,
there were about 1,000 pages.
Wolf is in them, and
the other things.
There's a certain limit
in this day and age
to books, which is
approximately 500 pages.
I mean, that's--
BOB KAHN: I've read
books bigger than that.
WALTER ISAACSON: I know,
but I meant-- not many.
BOB KAHN: I read "Godel,
Escher, and Bach" in one swoop.
WALTER ISAACSON:
That's what, 600 pages?
Not much more.
BOB KAHN: I think it
was more than that.
WALTER ISAACSON:
That's a good book.
BOB KAHN: One sitting.
WALTER ISAACSON: Yeah,
but you know what?
Not everybody can read
"Godel, Escher, and Bach"
in one sitting.
You're not the best focus group
for the publishing industry.
But I did decide, hey, I want
to keep it in the package,
and I'm going to
get to why we don't
need to do that in the future.
So I ended up picking 12.
I just made a list
finally at the end,
12 major things I wanted to do.
I wanted to do the computer,
and so I focused on those three,
and by that, I mean the
people who really began it,
not Control Data Corporation
and others that pick it up.
I wanted to do the transistor,
the microchip, video games,
because I actually do
think that they were
important in the
interactive computing realm.
I wanted to do software
and how original
operating system
software, and the women
as well as men who did it.
And I go down the
web and others.
I could have picked
many other things
and I could have picked
many other people
in each one of those
categories, but I said, OK,
who made a conceptual leap that
I really feel passionate about?
Now, I know that leaves
out more than it includes,
but it makes for a narrative.
The problem with
narrative history
is narrative is defined by
you leave out a lot of things
so that you have a thread.
BOB KAHN: But that's
really interesting,
because if you focus it
all on the conceptual leap,
you minimize the contributions
of the people who actually
then implemented those ideas.
As an engineer, and I think
Vint would agree with this, too,
a lot of the details are in
making things actually work.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Right, and I really
try to emphasize in
the book that you
have to execute on
vision, and that's
why I focus on the engineers and
the software engineers of ENIAC
more than on this
conceptual leap
that Atanasoff has at
Iowa State because he
doesn't implement it.
And I hope-- I mean,
you can be the judge--
that with Fairchild
and Intel, we
get into a lot of the
engineers who are making it.
Let me leap forward
to what I hope
is the solution to this,
which is I would love it,
and Google is the best
place to invent it
with Google Docs,
networks, everything else,
and I've tried.
I've worked with people.
I'm still not there
yet, but I would
be quite happy to take this
book and make it a curated wiki
Google Doc, and I have done
that with some of the chapters.
It's why Dan
Bricklin-- you say, why
is Bricklin in there
for doing VisiCalc?
Well frankly, because he
gave me all of his documents
when he read an early draft
and it was on Medium, which
is like a Google Doc
place where people put in.
I think the book
of the future will
be a collaborative,
crowd-sourced,
and yet author curated,
meaning you just can't run off
anywhere, multimedia,
where, let us
say you want to talk about--
let's pick one thing--
how the planar process worked
and how the planar process led
to the microprocessor being
easily invented at Intel.
I would love the videos, I'd
love the original documents,
I'd love people to upload
those things, because online,
on a Google Book, I'll call
it, you couldn't make it
not 500 pages but
500,000 pages and video.
BOB KAHN: Is that still
your book at that point?
WALTER ISAACSON:
And that's why I
would like to curate
it, meaning that you're
going to have fights.
I won't name names
again, but even
with your friends who
were originally there
with packet switching, just like
the revision wars in Wikipedia
fought with more intensity than
we seem to be fighting wars
in the real world
these days, you
would have to have some
curator who would say, OK,
enough of this
fighting about who
came up with packet switching.
Let's try to just put it
all and synthesize it.
But I suspect, like
Wikipedia, the crowd
would also curate pretty well.
I also think, and
this is the next thing
I would love Google to do,
for that to be really fair,
there has to be
a payment system.
I would be happy to
put this book online--
I shouldn't say
this too publicly,
but after "Steve Jobs" I'm not
looking for more book sales.
VINT CERF: This
only just came out,
so don't say that to
your publisher yet.
He'll cancel your book tour.
WALTER ISAACSON: But let us
say that Vint Cerf and Bob
Kahn looked at this
and said, there
are 22 things you
really left out
of the RFC process
and the ARPANET,
and then the TCP/IP process
we went through in '73,
I think it was.
And here's all our
documents, and here's
somebody who should
have gotten more credit,
here's his picture,
here is an interview
I've just done with him.
I want to put all that up.
You would be doing that, as you
would be editing a Wikipedia
entry, just for the
good of the commons,
but there would be
other people who
might want to contribute
and actually make
a living out of it.
BOB KAHN: So this would be
like sticky notes on your book?
WALTER ISAACSON:
Well, it would be
like making my book
into a Wikipedia page
where everybody could
put documents up,
and I would love the
royalties to then
be allocated in some
crypto currency way
that Google could invent,
so that if people are paying
$30 for this book and
they read these parts,
the royalties get allocated
to whoever contributed.
VINT CERF: So that's
a challenge before us.
WALTER ISAACSON: And
I hope my next book,
I'd love to write about Louis
Armstrong, but you need music.
I would need a Wynton
Marsalis to say,
here's the 17-bar cadenza
that opens "West End Blues,"
and here's how he changed it
from King Oliver's version,
but that would need to be
crowd-sourced and multimedia,
and I want Google
to invent that.
BOB KAHN: I always thought that
one of the really nice things
that historians rely on
are crafted treatises
on various topics.
There's a lady that
Vint and I both know
who wrote some monographs on
infrastructure development.
She would not write a
single sentence in there
that she couldn't curate from
some well known historian who
quoted something
and made a point.
So how do you treat
something like this
when the only real
authority behind it
is the party who
put it all together
and everything else is all
this other stuff that's
stuck in there?
WALTER ISAACSON: This
is much more footnoted,
source noted than, say,
the Steve Jobs book,
which mainly came from
interviews with Steve
and 60 or 70 other
people around him.
I am probably not
the best reporter
in the history of the world.
I just saw Bob Woodward
when I was walking here.
He's much better.
I'm probably not the
best academic historian.
I mean, somebody like you just
talked about who does that.
I do have, I hope--
BOB KAHN: Yeah, but
you write so well.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Thank you so much.
But I also have, I
hope, the ability
to combine historical resource,
like looking at the monographs
or whatever, with just being
able to call Gordon Moore
and saying, I'm going
to get in the car,
I'm going to drive
to Woodside, you've
got to spend all
day with me, and I'm
lucky because I've
been at Time Magazine.
Gordon Moore, who would
not take the phone
call of my second cousin
from Louisiana if he said,
I want to drive up to Woodside,
I get to see these people.
So I do a lot of interviews.
There are about 100 or so,
including you and others,
in the book, but I also go
back to the papers and the IEEE
and everybody, your
collaborated document
on the invention of the
internet, a little original Len
Kleinrock and Paul Baran papers.
There's no quote in
this book, I think,
or no major quote in this book
or assertion that's not source
cited by name on the
record, but all history
is just the next
draft of history.
There will be people who
will build upon this.
I think I bring some
journalistic skills.
Other people bring better
historical-- Janet Abbate,
others who have done
great academic histories
of the internet.
And someday, when it's all part
of this curated, crowd-sourced
system, you'll be able
to hop around and get
whatever you want.
VINT CERF: So I
have a suggestion.
He was threatening to
turn the tables us,
so maybe we should
do that, and I'd
like to let everybody else have
some time to ask questions.
BOB KAHN: Are you trying
to filibuster against that?
WALTER ISAACSON:
No, I'm trying to--
VINT CERF: I figured
I managed to--
WALTER ISAACSON: I have spent
30 years as a journalist.
I love asking the questions.
Here I am having the people
who actually invented
the internet ask me questions.
I'm going, that's wacky.
I should be asking
them questions.
BOB KAHN: Actually,
when you read the book,
the impression that
it gives, which
I thought is the one
you were trying to give,
is that collaboration
is really everything
and all these people really
created the internet.
WALTER ISAACSON: Right.
I really wanted
to, and it is true.
I'm trying to show
collaboration, enough
credit to go around, and it
is true, I sort of think.
And then afterwards, people
say, you didn't give me
quite enough credit,
or worse yet, they're
suing [INAUDIBLE]
over the patents.
But generally, collaboration
is really cool.
And I'll start, there's two
real segments of the internet.
BOB KAHN: So when you
point out Vint and myself,
what makes you single us out?
I mean, we could
give you our views,
but I'm wondering
what your views are.
WALTER ISAACSON: I
will turn it around
and make you give the views.
I'll say that there's
two great phases
in the creation of the internet.
Phase one was the
creation of ARPANET.
I think you were
at BBN probably--
BOB KAHN: I actually
was a system designer.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Yeah, at BBN, right?
Bolt, Beranek, and Newman, which
was a private company but still
very associated with
MIT to some extent.
BOB KAHN: And Harvard.
WALTER ISAACSON: And
Harvard, and to some extent
with the government, because
you had from Larry Roberts,
and I guess the
original Licklider,
you had contracts to do
what was unfortunately
named IMPs, Interface
Message Processors, which--
BOB KAHN: Why is
that unfortunate?
WALTER ISAACSON: Well, because
when BBN got the contract--
BOB KAHN: I actually
have the little slide
that Ted Kennedy sent.
WALTER ISAACSON: Yeah.
I'm going to do a Ted
Kennedy joke here,
which I'll let Dr.
Kahn do the punchline.
BOB KAHN: I gave it
to Licklider's wife
at the ceremony.
VINT CERF: Wait, let
him do his punchline.
WALTER ISAACSON: They
don't know the joke
before you do the punch--
VINT CERF: It's his punchline.
Go ahead.
WALTER ISAACSON: No.
It's the Interface
Message Processor,
and it's awarded to BBN, which
is in Ted Kennedy's district,
and he sends a telegram
congratulating you
on getting the--
BOB KAHN: Inter-faith
message processor.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Which, by the way,
is a wonderfully telling slip,
because it was inter-faith,
in many ways.
VINT CERF: Well
actually, he thought
he was congratulating
them on what
he thought was an
ecumenical effort.
WALTER ISAACSON: It was.
It was the ultimate
ecumenical effort.
VINT CERF: An inter-faith
message processor,
the Jews and the
Muslims and the--
WALTER ISAACSON: We basically
call them routers now,
but these were the machines
that were going to--
BOB KAHN: Actually, I would say
we call them packet switches
now.
WALTER ISAACSON: Yeah, but
these were the machines
that would be sent to the
original nodes on ARPANET that
would be an inter-faith or
interface between the host
machine and the
rest of the network.
BOB KAHN: So Vint, you mean
if it wasn't ecumenical,
we wouldn't have gotten
that thank you note?
VINT CERF: I don't know.
It was supposed to be something
that was nondenominational.
The whole idea was
it's non-proprietary,
and it was, from
Kennedy's choice of words,
nondenominational,
and that's very true.
The IMPs were there,
packet switches,
to form this uniform,
homogeneous network
to deal with an extremely
heterogeneous collection
of computers that
were on the edges.
And that demonstration,
to take your point
about these two phases
of the whole process.
The first phase demonstrated
that heterogeneous computers
and operating
systems could be made
to communicate across
a homogeneous network,
and that was the
beginning of understanding
what was possible.
WALTER ISAACSON: And it was the
ultimate collaborative process,
which is what I'm
going to ask you about,
because if somebody had to
say, if you could show me
the true nature of a
collaborative process-- this is
early on, before we're
getting to the internet TCP/IP
process-- is, how are these
IMPs going to communicate
with host computers
and each other?
And everybody vaguely
expected that, either
from the bosses of BBN or
the bosses in the Pentagon,
the word would be sent
down, but instead, it's
done collaboratively
mainly by graduate student,
including you were
a graduate student.
BOB KAHN: There are actually
two parts of that process.
The one that had the computers
talking to the other computers
was what led to the
host to host protocols.
That's one Vint was
very involved in,
along with a number
of other people.
And the second part that had to
do with how the machines talked
to these interface message
processors was in a BBN report
that I authored
called "BBN Report
1822," so that interface was
all called the 1822 interface,
and that was a combination of
how the hardware would work,
because you had different
word size machines, how
the software would
work, and that
was a precursor to having the
machines talk to each other.
WALTER ISAACSON: Right.
And the one I focus
on, because you
asked, why do you
focus on things,
is the request for
comment process,
because it was so collaborative
and collegial, even the phrase
that Steve Crocker, who you
turned me onto and I went
and interviewed for the book.
He's just a graduate
student with you,
and instead of having
the graduate student say,
here's the way we
should do it, he said,
I had to think of
a name that would
make people feel like they
were collaborators in this.
And so when we sent them
out, I didn't want to say,
here's our plan or our proposal.
He was standing in the shower
at his girlfriend's house,
he said, and it
came to him that he
should call it a
request for comment
because it was so open and
inviting, as opposed to, here's
what you're supposed to do.
Let me let Vint tell the story
from there, and then Bob,
but you were in the RFC
process, weren't you?
VINT CERF: Yes, but to
draw a little bit further
on what Bob was talking about,
in order to have communication
at all, you need to have
commonality, and so the 1822
hardware and software
interface between the host that
were heterogeneous and the
IMPs that were homogeneous
was the first important
piece of commonality.
The next piece of commonality
is that the computers
at the edges of the net
needed to share something
in common so they
could communicate
with each other, packet
formats and protocols,
handshaking, and so on.
That's what Steve
and I and others
worked on, the host
to host protocols.
Steve and I and the
others, Jon Postel,
were graduate students in Len
Kleinrock's laboratory at UCLA,
and we kept thinking that
somebody, like Larry Roberts,
who was in charge of
the project at ARPA,
would come out and tell us
what we were supposed to do,
and he didn't.
So we thought, well, we
have to do something.
BOB KAHN: He didn't know.
He was expecting
you to tell him.
VINT CERF: Len didn't
tell us either.
So basically, it's
graduate students who
are scratching their
heads saying, well,
we have to do something.
So Steve did a
beautiful job, exactly
as you say, organizing
this group, which
spanned across a dozen
different universities,
looking at not only how to
get the computers to exchange
postcards, so to speak, but
also to build on top of that.
So this notion of layering
came out very early
on in the ARPANET history.
We learned an enormous
amount from that experiment.
Email came along in 1971, two
years after we turned the IMPs
on at UCLA, Santa Barbara,
SRI International, and Utah.
BBN, where Bob was still,
was pumping out IMPs,
and they were popping
up on the network, one
a month for quite awhile.
So we were experiencing utility
from this homogeneous network,
and got pretty
excited about that.
So that's the first
phase, as you said.
WALTER ISAACSON: And to me--
and tell me if I'm wrong--
but the notion that you all
did this to an RFC process
I found fascinating
because it almost
seems like it's ingrained in the
genetic code of the internet,
which is a collaborative
system, built collaboratively.
VINT CERF: This, I think,
is fairly important.
Bob, I think you've been
very articulate about this.
Not only did we have
a bunch of people
who shared this
common excitement
and view that we could
make this stuff work,
but the institutions
that have been created,
arising from the ARPANET project
and the internet project,
were equally bottom
up and collaborative,
and this notion of
multi-stakeholder models,
where all the parties who
have a stake in something
participate in the
development, whether it's
the technical development
or development of policy,
infuses all of this
internet environment.
I have to say that
Steve's trailblazing--
WALTER ISAACSON: Steve Crocker.
VINT CERF: Steve Crocker's
trail blazing-- that's right.
You would think
Jobs, wouldn't you?
So Steve Crocker's
trail blazing I think
helped set that tone, and all
the institutions who came out
after that had a very
similar character.
BOB KAHN: The
counterpart to that,
though, is that these computers
were all linked together
through a single
network called ARPANET,
and the process by which
the ARPANET was built
involved DARPA, generally
in the form of Larry
with a group that
be coordinated with,
essentially writing
the requirement specs.
Half a second delay across the
net, 1,000 bit packets or less,
and so forth.
But the actual
building of that net
was much more insular than
any of the other things that
went on.
In fact, there was
almost a desire by BBN
to keep it that way.
In addition to playing
a technical role there
that was pretty important,
I was the only one
that was assigned to deal
with the external community.
That was my job.
If anybody had a question,
I was the only one
they knew of
because nobody else,
they were not
interested in having
them be deviated from
a very short time frame
to get something done with
questions from the community.
And this BBN Report 1822 was
one of the hardest things
I ever wrote my life because I
had to make a document that all
of the sites that
would connect had
to be able to read
and understand,
and I have to solve
their problems,
at the same time
abstracting out everything
about the net that they
didn't need to know about.
So it was an intellectual
exercise of the first order
to actually write that
report in a way that
didn't get into so much detail.
I get so many questions about,
exactly how does the routing
work, and exactly how
does the buffering work,
and how does the
[INAUDIBLE] control work?
WALTER ISAACSON: You just
answered the question
of why I have to leave
some stuff out, too.
Whenever you're writing
something like that.
I want to ask you all
a question, before we
get to the internet TCP/IP,
which is the next step,
is there's a great
controversy, which I show
both sides of in this book, as
to whether or not the ARPANET,
I'll call it, was designed
with partly surviving
a nuclear attack in mind.
BOB KAHN: Yeah.
Vint wasn't internal
to DARPA at the time,
and I wasn't there
when it first started,
but I read a lot of the
internal documentation on that
and talked to a
number of people.
There are two or three
points of view on this.
One is, and you call it out in
your book, Charlie Herzfeld,
who Taylor likes to talk
about the 10 minute story,
and you clarify
that it was really
multiple years that [INAUDIBLE].
WALTER ISAACSON: I
hate clarifying stories
that are so good you
want them to just
be told the way
people like that.
BOB KAHN: That one, and that the
Kleinrock story about sending
the L and the O. That was years
before we had the protocols,
years before we had email
systems and the like,
but they're nice stories.
When it comes to the
actual implementation, what
was motivating the
folks in the office
was the economics of sharing
computer resources that
were very expensive.
I can recall Harvard
got a big disk.
At the time, it was
probably $1 million,
and so some other university
like Carnegie Mellon said,
we need one, too.
Well, why spend another
$1 million on Carnegie
when they could share the one at
Harvard, save DARPA some money?
Part of it was the economics,
but if you actually
look at the
documentation, it talks
about needing to build this net
to facilitate computer resource
sharing, so there were some
interesting technical problems.
It points out that
the network itself
could have a big effect
on communications.
But this was at
the office level,
so there was nothing that
pervaded the office activities
that had anything to do with
nuclear survivability or any
of the military aspects.
What Steve Lukasik wrote about,
and he's written very clearly
about this over the years, was
that at his level and above,
the reason they thought this
was a good investment for DARPA
to do is because it could
have all of this impact.
VINT CERF: Distributed.
There's no central
hub to the internet.
BOB KAHN: It could be
reliable communications.
VINT CERF: And it will route
around any Soviet attack.
BOB KAHN: It could be a
better solution for command
and control and so forth.
So to say that that wasn't
there because the office didn't
see it would be denying
what was going on elsewhere.
VINT CERF: If I
may read, there's
a very funny exchange
in here about that.
Go ahead.
WALTER ISAACSON: This is the one
I think you're talking about,
which is when Lukasik,
who said, hey,
we were doing it to
survive a nuclear attack.
You down at the office
level didn't know that,
but that's why we were funding
it, and Crocker says, no,
you weren't.
So anyway, I interviewed
them both, and--
BOB KAHN: Yeah, I know.
Crocker changed his mind.
WALTER ISAACSON: And
Lukasik says, "I was on top
and you were on
the bottom," this
is what he says
to Steve Crocker,
"so you really had no
idea of what was going on
and why we were doing it."
To which, when I
told Crocker this,
Crocker responded, "I was on the
bottom and you were on the top,
so you had no idea what
was really going on."
That's the way life is sometimes
in a collaborative process.
VINT CERF: I get to add
one little codicil to this
because the original
work that Paul Baran did
on survivable networks,
the 11 volume series
called "On Distributed
Communication,"
was all about building a
survivable command and control
network.
It was digital in nature but
it was caring digital voice.
Think about this.
He's doing this
around 1960 before we
have integrated circuits
or anything else.
So he's looking at survivable
command and control,
then along comes this ARPANET
thing and for many of us,
it was a resource
sharing project.
Then internet comes
along, we come to that,
and I remember thinking,
when it was my responsibility
to manage the program, that
we should actually demonstrate
that the TCP/IP protocols
would in fact allow
you to survive a nuclear attack.
So although I may be
jumping ahead a little bit,
towards the end of
my tenure at DARPA,
we actually put packet radios
in the strategic aircraft
and flew them around and
artificially disabled
the ARPANET, broke
it up into pieces
and reassembled it using
packet radios in the air
and on the ground using
TCP/IP, to demonstrate
that you could actually
make a survival network.
WALTER ISAACSON: And
since women programmers
don't often get
their due in history,
you had a great
woman, Perlman right?
VINT CERF: Radia Perlman
did a fabulous job
of designing the routing
system that would recover,
by figuring out what
the broken segments were
and how to glue
them back together.
She did a beautiful job.
WALTER ISAACSON: Let me,
Bob, if I may, leap to I
think what would be spring of
1973, if I remember correctly.
What you have is
ARPANET, and as you say,
I don't do enough
with the NSF net,
and there are other nets,
and ALOHAnet, and all--
VINT CERF: Of course,
they don't exist yet.
BOB KAHN: I want to
stipulate for the record,
I didn't think you
could cover everything.
I was just asking why
you picked what you did.
WALTER ISAACSON: But
anyway, all of a sudden,
there are a whole lot of
packet switch networks,
but they don't
talk to each other.
VINT CERF: There were only four.
WALTER ISAACSON: Only four.
ALOHAnet--
VINT CERF: At that
point, you had ALOHA,
you had packet radio,
you had packet satellite,
and you had ehternet.
WALTER ISAACSON: And
then you had ARPANET.
VINT CERF: And you had
ARPANET, so there's five.
BOB KAHN: You're going at
the story from the back end.
I would like to tell
it from the front end.
WALTER ISAACSON: Tell
BOB KAHN: The front
end was we had
the ARPANET was DARPA
had commissioned that.
We built it.
I then go to DARPA
and I show up there
in roughly the end
of October of 1972,
and I go there to
start a program
that automated manufacturing,
which the Congress later kills.
VINT CERF: They're back
at it again, though.
I mean, automated manufacturing.
WALTER ISAACSON: Or
killing programs.
VINT CERF: Have you seen how
the Tesla-- anyway, go ahead.
BOB KAHN: So when
they kill the program,
I'm thinking, all right,
what I signed up for here,
I'm going to go back to
MIT, where I had a standing
offer to go join
the faculty again
because I had started my
career out there after getting
a doctorate from
Princeton and before going
to BBN on a leave of absence.
So I was thinking.
Larry Roberts, who's running the
office, persuades me, stay on.
You've been so involved in
networking, don't do that.
So I agree to give it a shot,
but only if I can have nothing
to do with the ARPANET
because I did that before.
I wanted to do something new.
VINT CERF: Well, you would
have been constrained,
in some sense, because
you were at BBN
and they were
still a contractor,
and you can't manage
them as a program manager
after having been at BBN--
BOB KAHN: This was before we
had conflict of interest rules.
I mean, I got my own ability
to manage conflict, so not
a problem for me.
VINT CERF: No
conflict, no interest.
BOB KAHN: Not a problem for me.
But I finally said, all
right, I'll give it a shot.
I started the packet radio
program after I got to DARPA,
and I started the packet
satellite program as a program.
Now, let me just say,
Larry had started
to fund BBN to turn a
satellite IMP into one that
could use a satellite
as a modem relay.
And one of the issues that
I had to deal with was, was
that a good idea or not?
I thought, no, it wasn't.
Let's make the satellite
net a separate net
by splitting it
out, and this was
an interesting technical
discussion we had with BBN,
because they were of the opinion
that this would be much more
reliable if everything
was in an IMP,
but that meant you could never
do the equivalent of putting
a router in between it.
You'd just lose complete
control because everything
was memory to memory transfers.
So we ended up
building a separate net
on a satellite net.
When Larry funded them, there
were no domestic satellites
at all.
There was no plan to use
a satellite anywhere.
And so I ended up
negotiating with COMSAT,
and then an Intel sat
to actually set up
tariffs that would
enable this to happen,
and then we set up the program.
The one who ran that program
technically was a fellow
named Irwin Jacobs, who later
became the founder of Qualcom.
I was sort of chief architect of
the packet radio program, which
became essentially the
forerunner of today's CVMA
technology.
WALTER ISAACSON: The point
is that you have these
all of these networks and
they don't interconnect.
BOB KAHN: These three
networks show up,
and that was what motivated
me to work on the problem
of inter-networking them, and
I had some architectural--
WALTER ISAACSON: Let me pause
right there because when I
heard the word
"inter-networking," I said,
I get it.
That's where
internet comes from.
Is that right?
BOB KAHN: That's
where it came from.
And so I had that as a goal.
I had some architectural
principles.
We knew about putting-- we
didn't call them routers then,
we called them gateways.
But I came from a
communications background,
and so I was very comfortable
with building things that
could move the bits around,
but I was less comfortable
what the computers would do
with them when they got that.
And Vint and I had
collaborated a lot
on the ARPANET side of things,
me on the communications part,
him on the computing part.
He knew more about how
you embed these protocols
into the end computers.
I approached them at
one point and said,
look, here's what
I'm trying to do
and here's a whole
architectural approach.
Here's what I really don't know.
I don't know about
what it will take
in these different machines.
We agreed to collaborate, and
based on that collaboration,
I think both parts of
it came out better.
We were able to improve
the communications part,
we were able to
improve the end part.
I've had many collaborations,
but the one with Vint
was probably one of
the best, and we've
stayed pretty good friends
over the whole time.
VINT CERF: In spite of that.
BOB KAHN: In spite
of everything, right.
WALTER ISAACSON:
That really does
show that this
was a partnership,
this was collaboration.
BOB KAHN: Bit that's
where it came from.
It came from the need to connect
all these different nets.
WALTER ISAACSON: So explain how
you turned that into TCP/IP.
BOB KAHN: Well, we
did it together.
VINT CERF: He and I
spent six months trying
to sort all this out, and
eventually, this notion
of gateway-- the system sort
of emerged out of requirements.
You have a bunch
of networks and we
weren't allowed to
change any of them,
and the question
is, well, if they
can't know that they're part
of a distributed system,
how do we link them together?
The conclusion was
you needed something
in between that knew how
to talk to both networks
and would glue them
together even though they
didn't know they were connected.
Then the other problem is
that the hosts at the edges
needed to be able to say
something like, send this
to another network, but there
was no language for that
because--
WALTER ISAACSON: It was
like putting a postcard
in another envelope?
VINT CERF: Well,
the first problem
is language because the
network that you were connected
to locally had no vocabulary
for even understanding,
take this thing and send
it to some other net.
Every net thought it was
the only net in the world.
BOB KAHN: I have to
tell you what addressing
was like in the ARPANET,
16-bit addresses.
When you sent something,
you said, essentially,
send it to this wire.
Imagine that every wire are
on the network was numbered.
So you say, send
this to wire 17,
and what was supposed to
be attached to wire 17
was a big computer, so that
worked fine on the ARPANET.
But if wire 17 then went
to some other net, which
had a whole bunch of computers,
which of those computers
was it for?
There was no way that
language could describe it.
VINT CERF: You
couldn't say that,
so we had to invent the
internet protocol addressing.
BOB KAHN: That's where
IP addresses came from.
VINT CERF: And then we realized
that, in addition to that,
of course, we had to make sure
that all the data that we sent
in these little
postcard size pieces
would be received and
reassembled at the other end,
and we knew that
some of the networks,
like the packet radio net and
the ethernet, would be lossy.
There would be
radio shadow, there
would be jamming and
all kinds of things,
so we had to, on an
end to end basis,
make sure that the
communication was reliable.
WALTER ISAACSON: So how did you
do that with the transmission
control protocol?
VINT CERF: Transmission
control protocol.
Actually, the first papers that
we wrote had only one protocol.
It was called TCP,
and it did everything.
BOB KAHN: It had IP
integrated inside.
VINT CERF: It solved
the addressing problem.
It solved the end to end
retransmission and filtering
out of duplicates, flow
control, and reordering,
and everything was all
part of the one protocol.
But after a few iterations,
finding some bugs
in the design, several people
beat us over the head and said,
we really need a way of
delivering things really,
really quickly even if
not everything gets there.
So we split the
internet protocol out
from the TCP part, the
end to end reliable part,
and then created something
called User Datagram Protocol
so we could handle
real time traffic.
WALTER ISAACSON: Let me
ask you a question I didn't
ask for the book, which is,
if you had to do it all over
again knowing what you
know now, what would you
have designed differently?
BOB KAHN: I would have
started with the digital logic
architecture that I've been
working on for the last 20
years, but that's not fair
because it's like saying,
how would radio
communications in this country
have evolved if
the semiconductor
chip was available in 1915?
You can't run that
Gedankenexperiment anymore.
VINT CERF: But there
are things that I
wish that we could have
done that we didn't,
like I wish that we had picked
128-bit address space instead
of a 32-bit address space.
We wouldn't have to
go through this pain
of the IPv6 transition.
BOB KAHN: What makes you
think 128 bits is enough?
VINT CERF: Well,
it might not be,
but it'll be enough
until after we're dead.
Then it doesn't matter.
WALTER ISAACSON: Let me
talk about more consumer
friendly things, rather than
addressable space, which
is things like, is there
too much anonymity built
into the internet?
Would we be better off if
people were a little bit more
responsible for
what they put up?
BOB KAHN: I think that
identity in the internet
is really important.
I would like to see
us come to the point
where everybody has unique and
persistent identifiers that
resolve to reasonable state
information about them,
and they can have
multiple identities,
depending on the role
they want to play.
And one of those roles we must
absolutely support, I think,
is the role of anonymous.
WALTER ISAACSON: So you'd have
an anonymous, pseudonymous
thing.
BOB KAHN: You can decide
how you want to participate.
If I want to participate
as a government employee,
I'm probably going to give a
government employee identifier.
If I'm going to participate as
a representative of my company,
that's a different one.
And then maybe the services
and the opportunities you get
are determined by how
definitive your identity is.
WALTER ISAACSON:
But in other words,
you could create an internet
in which there's secure ID,
and when I'm dealing
with my bank,
I would have to use
that identity when
I'm dealing with them.
BOB KAHN: Well, if this
were back in 1972 and Vint
and I were doing it, I would
say, yes, we could do that.
Today, I don't think
anybody can do that anymore
because there's so many places
and parties around the globe.
We can work toward it.
VINT CERF: I actually think
it's possible to do some things,
to create strongly
authenticated identities,
and also to achieve
some anonymity,
but we're running out
of time, it turns out.
BOB KAHN: But Vint,
I agree with that.
I was harping on his
question about you.
You could do it.
VINT CERF: We've got to
let these other folks ask
questions, too.
WALTER ISAACSON:
Having three moderators
is always hard, right?
VINT CERF: So I've
got one question.
Patrice?
And then anybody else,
get your hands up.
BOB KAHN: This is also my wife.
I saw her come in.
AUDIENCE: I'm going
to throw a softball.
I've been sitting here looking
at your title, "Innovators."
I started life out years
ago as a copyright attorney.
I'm very much interested
in the creative process,
and I've heard a lot
tonight about collaboration
as if the spark of innovation
doesn't quite matter anymore,
that it's some kind of muddled
group, they get together,
and they come up with the idea.
Now, I've worked with Bob
and Vint over the years,
and I was listening
tonight to their discussion
of the early days, which
that's an interesting story,
but they each brought
their own innovation to it
so you could have a finer
level of granularity.
So you can have a
collaboration, but if you
have a bunch of dullards and
one really bright card, then
the collaboration really
is a useless concept.
You have to look at
the innovation, what
is the creative force?
I'm trying to nuance
a bit because I
heard the drumbeat of
collaboration a bit much.
WALTER ISAACSON: That's why
it's a long book in a way
because a lot of
collaborative teams
don't work particularly well.
I loved both the RFC
process, and then
what you all talk about, about
the TCP/IP process, which
is two people each
bringing, you're
slightly more of a
communications mindset,
whatever, but it ends up
being a collaboration where
innovation really happens.
Now, by the way, that
happens with Steve Jobs
and Steve Wozniak.
They are bringing different
things to the party.
It certainly happened with
Andy Grove and Bob Noyce.
One's a congregationalist who
loves singing madrigal songs
in a congregational
church, and the other
had to swim to escape the
Nazis and the Communists.
I even tried to do that
with Benjamin Franklin,
because he was not the
smartest of the founders--
I mean, Jefferson,
Madison, and all--
but he was the one who was the
glue who could bring together
a Washington who's
indispensable,
passionate people like
John and Sam Adams,
smart people like
Madison and Jefferson.
It's almost like
a baseball team.
You need a pitcher, a
catcher, you need the manager,
you also need
utility infielders.
What makes for a collaboration
that has both a visionary
but also executors?
BOB KAHN: Walter, who was
the smartest of the founders?
WALTER ISAACSON: The
smartest of the founders
may have in-- I don't know.
It's a good question,
and "smart" means
many different things.
I think Franklin
was really smart
because he knew how to
bring smart people together,
which is a skill.
VINT CERF: Yeah,
but he was a twit.
WALTER ISAACSON: I think Madison
was intellectually-- what?
VINT CERF: He was a twit.
WALTER ISAACSON: A twit?
Franklin?
VINT CERF: Yeah, Franklin.
Well, I read your book.
You spelled it out.
WALTER ISAACSON: John Adams
was a twit, not Franklin.
I think Madison was the
most creative mind there.
Obviously, Jefferson
is very fertile mind,
but we don't have to get into
a debate on the founders,
as much as I have my
problems with Jefferson that
go to the limits
of intelligence.
VINT CERF: Let's let the
audience ask questions.
WALTER ISAACSON: Susan?
AUDIENCE: No, no.
Who else has a question here?
WALTER ISAACSON:
You're the moderator.
I shouldn't be able
to pick out people.
AUDIENCE: I'm Alex Howard.
I've enjoyed reading your books,
following along, and using
the internet for some time.
I couldn't help noticing as I
opened this up that you have
Ken Kesey in there, and
Stewart Brand, who you mention.
If you look at the
people in this book,
it's an American and British
story in a lot of ways.
Since we're in DC and people
think about public policy
here a lot, how you create
the conditions for innovation,
if you look at that story,
how do you do that now,
as people are thinking about
national competitiveness,
about education,
about being inclusive,
because STEM is a big issue?
The impact of you
writing about this
has caused quite a stir, too,
to recall the limit of ENIAC.
It's important that the
original computers were women.
When you think about the
conditions for innovation,
what have you learned from
that, and what have you
all seen, too, in terms of
the things being focused on?
BOB KAHN: This is not a
question about genetics, right?
AUDIENCE: Absolutely not.
No, it's a condition about how
we create the next big thing.
WALTER ISAACSON:
But it is a question
about the primordial stew
from which the DNA emerges.
VINT CERF: So at Google, I think
the most important ingredient
for innovation is
permission to fail
and the willingness to
let you try crazy ideas.
The founders are
willfully determined
that we will push the envelope.
That's why we have
a Google X and we've
got a moonshot
experiments and things
that, like self driving cars.
I think this attitude also
shows up in the Silicon Valley,
where venture capital is
willing to accept risk.
They know that maybe only 10%
of the things they invest in
will actually work out.
I don't think it's a
peculiarly American attitude,
but it is an American
attitude, and I
don't think we've lost that.
I think we still have
it and we should use it.
BOB KAHN: And that's also true
in DARPA to a large extent.
VINT CERF: Oh, absolutely.
BOB KAHN: They shoot high
and are willing to fail,
even though they don't fail
too often because they often
don't shoot as high as they
start out shooting for.
WALTER ISAACSON:
I'd like to ask you
a question on that, which is--
VINT CERF: They're supposed
to be asking questions.
WALTER ISAACSON: Oh, sorry.
BOB KAHN: A lot of
success stories.
WALTER ISAACSON: Well, I'll
just make a quick statement
that I think we have blown
it a bit in government
because it used to be you
were allowed to fail, and now
any little gaffe you
make in this day and age,
you'll never get confirmed,
you'll get run out of town.
In Silicon Valley, at least,
or in other innovative places,
you're allowed to fail.
I have Ken Kesey in
the book because it
was a rebellious
attitude that happens
in the late '60s and early '70s
in the Bay Area that involves
"The Electric
Kool-Aid Acid Test"
and Stewart Brand, and also
Doug Engelbart, as you know,
with the mother of all demos.
It's almost like one of the
electric Kool-Aid acid tests.
It has Brand as the impresario.
So part of that
cultural stew was
the rebellious counterculture,
anti-war, anti-authoritarian,
hippie, acid test mentality
that has been written about
by Fred Turner very well,
by Steve Levy, John Markoff.
Many people have written
about that hacker mentality,
and it ties into the rebellious
as it allows you to fail.
VINT CERF: Let's get
two or three questions
asked, and then
we'll try to respond
to them as a way
of getting more.
Let's start over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jim.
On the theme of collaboration,
with the internet
hopefully going to be accessible
by the next four billion people
on the earth's surface and
more than half the population,
in terms of the global
innovator community
and people's ability to
solve their own problems,
what would you like the internet
to help do in the future
to solve global problems, to
connect people to collaborate
on problems that seemingly
are insurmountable?
VINT CERF: So global
collaboration,
what can the internet do?
Let's get a couple more.
AUDIENCE: I really love "Steve
Jobs," the book, rather,
and I'd like to ask
Mr. Isaacson, what
are your impressions
of innovation
at Apple after the
passing of Mr. Jobs,
because it seems to
highlight that tension
between a strong singular
visionary and then
a collaborative team?
I think there is a
storyline that there's
been some drift since
you lost that visionary.
VINT CERF: OK.
So we've got
collaboration at Apple
and we have global
collaboration over the internet.
One more if there are?
If not, we'll try
to tackle those two.
There's one more here.
AUDIENCE: So Mr.
Isaacson, how did you
pick who the four people were
going to be on your book cover?
VINT CERF: All right.
AUDIENCE: I appreciate that
there's a woman up there.
VINT CERF: I'm
pretty sure we're not
going to be able to integrate
one answer to all that.
Let's start with the
last one, book cover.
How did you do that?
WALTER ISAACSON:
Boy, it was very
hard to do this book cover.
I'm used to writing biographies.
The Steve Jobs cover was
probably the most iconic cover,
Steve Jobs and a picture,
so that's the easiest one.
When you're doing something that
involves, say, 12 grand steps
and 30, 40 innovators,
how do you pick them?
In the end, it's Alan
Turing, if you're wondering,
who's on the bottom right.
You know the others,
Ada Lovelace.
VINT CERF: They're
there the bookends,
in some sense, and
then the rich guys.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that's what I saw.
WALTER ISAACSON: I think
that Steve Jobs and Bill
Gates are very
emblematic characters
of how you both have vision.
Also, you execute, and business
execution is part of it,
and collaboration.
If I'd had 10 people,
I could have put 10.
It was not a particularly
easy cover to do.
If you go back and you
can find, Google things
that are cached
from earlier times
on Amazon, there's
probably eight
covers that they went through
before they got to this one.
VINT CERF: Actually,
maybe you should
consider publishing a
book with multiple covers.
WALTER ISAACSON: Yeah.
At Time Magazine,
I used to do that.
It was a real gimmicky, but
especially every now and then,
you'd have four covers
for four different--
VINT CERF: If collaboration
was the intent,
I don't see collaborators
on the cover at all.
Anyway, just a gripe.
WALTER ISAACSON: Turing.
Turing was a collaborator.
VINT CERF: Well, mumble.
OK, so let's go back to
this collaboration question.
You've got this question,
how do you use the internet
to help solve global problems?
BOB KAHN: You want me
to take that one on?
VINT CERF: Go ahead.
BOB KAHN: I would
let's say you're
thinking of the
internet writ large now.
When I think of the
internet, I think about it
in terms of the protocols
and the procedures
that let you connect things.
That gets back to the
definition of what it is,
and then you can use it
for different things.
So it really gets
into how people
are going to get
together to solve some
of these global
problems and what role
the internet can play in it.
You asked the question
the other way around,
what can the
internet do for that,
and I would say that's the
wrong way to get at it.
The question is,
what global problem
are you trying to solve?
Is it clean water in
parts of the world that
don't have access
to clean water?
Is it how to get rid
of Ebola viruses?
Is it how to do
checkout of people
in airports when
they're coming in?
Is it how to deal
with better targeting
in the field for the military?
You can figure out what
problem you're concerned about
and then you can figure
out what a solution is,
and then you can ask, is
these an internet role
in all of that?
And most likely, there will be
because everything is disparate
and disconnected and you've
got to bring them all together.
I wouldn't phrase
it exactly the way
you did, starting
by asking about what
the internet can do for you.
It's the Kennedy
thing flipped around.
VINT CERF: Ask not what the
internet can do for you.
Ask what you can do
for the internet.
I actually want to draw
out of this another notion,
and that's the notion of
an enabling technology,
because if you look
at these stories,
all of them, what you see
is this scheme of things
linking the stories together.
Somebody creates
something, which
enables someone else
to do another thing.
This whole story is
all about enabling,
which I think is part of
the origin of your question.
What could the internet enable?
The thing it does
better anything
is it connects
stuff together that
was never connected before.
This casual idea that I can take
this can of Coke, for example,
or this book, put a chip in it,
and connect it to the internet
somehow is the
beginning of ideas
that people never
thought of before
because it wasn't possible.
Now it's possible.
BOB KAHN: Maybe you
don't connect it to it.
Maybe it's automatically part
of it when you put the chip in.
VINT CERF: Well, if we
ever get to the point
where we can have self
assembling devices
through biotechnology, then when
people say, what do you think,
computers grow on trees?
And you say, yeah,
let me show you.
Let's go back to the
collaboration at Apple,
though, because I think that
was a specific question for you
to try to tackle.
WALTER ISAACSON: Yeah.
I mean, when I first started
writing about Steve Jobs,
I thought he was an exception
to the rule about collaboration,
that he was a singular visionary
and his visionary did things.
And I asked him
at one point, what
was your most visionary
thing that you created,
and I thought he might say
the iPhone or iPad or the Mac.
And he said, no, creating
a particular product
or having a vision
for it is hard,
but the really hard thing
is creating a company that
lasts in which
people all know how
to execute with vision
on various things.
So the most important
thing I ever created
was Apple because I
realized it wasn't about me.
This is him talking.
I realized it was about a team
of people where I could walk in
and say, this sucks, or
this is great, or whatever,
but eventually, out of
that sturm und drang
would become a
particular product.
And I think the most
important thing,
and it's probably a
[INAUDIBLE] as here,
whether it's Google
or Apple or whatever
else, is to look at the
companies in which ingrained
in the genetic code was a
willingness to take risk
and to fail, and importance
about connecting beauty and art
and humanity, making our
machines more personal
so we felt intimate with them.
There were a lot of companies
that came up with great ideas--
Xerox at Xerox PARC, Bell
at Bell Labs, IBM, whatever.
They didn't innovate as
a team and take risks.
I see Google doing that.
I'm not just saying it
because I'm here with you all.
Google is one of the few really
big companies in which it's
still like, let's
shoot for the moon,
let's try some weird
things, and let's understand
the importance of teamwork.
I think Apple does that.
Apple still has a team.
What Steve did was not
just create a company.
People read my
book and they say,
Steve was pretty much of a
jerk at times, wasn't he?
I say, yeah, but don't
forget how it turns out.
He has the most loyal
people around him
who will march through walls
with him, who will collaborate,
who will stand up to him.
That team at Apple
is a lot tighter
than the teams at much
friendlier companies like HP.
BOB KAHN: Walter,
one of the things
that doesn't show
up in your book,
and yet one is often drawn
to a comparison between Apple
and Oracle, is Larry Ellison.
Is he out of the picture
here because you just
didn't have time to
get to him, or do you
think he doesn't
play a role here?
WALTER ISAACSON: I don't know.
You tell me.
BOB KAHN: No, you're the
one who wrote the book.
Why did you leave him out?
VINT CERF: Why don't
you [INAUDIBLE]?
WALTER ISAACSON: I
don't know that Oracle
was one of the 12 great
leaps of the digital age.
I think Larry Ellison's
a brilliant person,
but I don't find that the
creation of the Oracle systems
was up there with the
transistor, microchip,
the personal computer.
If I may, I would
love to get back--
BOB KAHN: I was just
curious as to your view.
WALTER ISAACSON: So
what Steve is able to do
is really show how you get
every player on a team,
somebody like a
Tim Cook, who knows
how to make things happen,
somebody like a Johnny
Ives, who understands
the design,
and he creates this tight team.
I think at Google, too,
there is this ability,
when you watch Larry
and Sergey, but then
all the people around them
and all the people here.
We can take risks, we can take
time off, we can collaborate,
and I think that the most
important thing for innovation
is not creating the
next new product
but creating the Apples, the
Googles, the Amazons, whatever
it may be, who are always
trying to do different things.
VINT CERF: I'm sorry.
It turns out that
this thing says 0S,
and I'm pretty sure that
doesn't mean osmium.
WALTER ISAACSON: It's
either zero seconds
or operating system.
VINT CERF: Right.
Or something.
So I have a suggestion.
Why don't we finish up here?
We have all kinds
of refreshments
out the doors here.
Why don't we thank our
author over here, Walter.
[APPLAUSE]
WALTER ISAACSON: And
let me make sure we
thank the two great heroes
of the theme of this book,
but also of the digital
age, Bob and Vint.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]